how many Cooper's does it take to cover
up a murder I've the answer and so many
more on Sweetwater secrets oh hi there
river babes
I'm Leanna Galera and this is your after
show for episode 213 chapter 26 the
tell-tale heart and I don't know about
you but my heart was thumping like crazy
during this week's episode and that's
not just because Sheryl blossom looked
amazing in her archery outfit now we
have a lot to discuss about this week's
episode so let's immediately dish about
the top headlines of the week in the
blue and gold breakdown all right guys
first up the episode picked up right
where we left off with Alice Cooper
frantically and flawlessly mopping up
the blood of a mysterious stranger just
typical of Cooper house lunacy well we
still don't know his name or exactly how
he was murdered Betty did discover that
he was a drug dealer and that chick had
contacted him for a fix that night but
what was chicks response no one is
buying the waters Betty and Alice did
their best to clean up the mess and
dispose of the body
but it was really Jughead and FP who
deserve all of the awards for best
killing cover-up great job guys next up
we can all stop screaming at our screens
that awful FBI informant storyline has
thankfully come to an end now after
agent Adams tried to blackmail Archie by
threatening Fred's business
Archie finally made his choice they
asked me to plant a bug in here I
smashed it with a hammer
luckily for archiekins he picked the
right side because as it turns out agent
Adams does not work for the FBI he
actually works for dun dun dun
Hermione Lodge are you confused yeah so
was she turns out Hermione hired Adams
to pose as an FBI agent to see if Archie
was truly trustworthy this was all some
kind of test
now that Archie has passed the test he's
been welcomed to the lodge family but
there's no word on if Veronica knew
about this plan which leads us straight
into this
weeks romance news in seven seconds in
heaven now this episode was not heavy
with the smooches but there was a
particularly sweet scene between
Veronica and Archie talking about their
confirmation confessionals now I'm
curious to see how Veronica's going to
react to the news that Archie is now
going to be in the lodge family's inner
circle especially after she told Hyrum
that she wants to keep her man far away
from their dysfunctional family drama as
for a Betty and Jughead well in between
the shock of covering up a murder she
and Jackie talked about their first time
and you guys it was pretty damn adorable
last night was amazing I'm also so happy
that Betty chose to finally be truthful
to Jughead and let him in on her killer
little secret you know what they say the
couple that covers up a murder together
stays together makes me look so easy now
let's keep going as my Riverdale rants
and raves in this week's this is
ambitious all right guys hisses - chick
yes chick I still hate you and here's
why now when he wasn't busy crying in
the corner and blubbering at the
breakfast table or sobbing off to the
side he was busy being oh so shady and
cutting up the Cooper family photo
albums look chick I don't like how
either but you're clearly hiding things
and I'm gonna get to the bottom of it
and while we're on the subject of the
Cooper's I'm sending so many hisses to
Hal for continuing his gag-worthy
relationship with Penelope blossom and
hisses to Alice for letting her motherly
affections for chick get in the way of
seeing that she's let a sociopath into
her home hisses - that fake FBI agent
and his endless supply of grandpa
fedoras hisses - the fact that Josie and
Kevin were barely in this episode and
hisses - the fact that Betty can never
truly seem to catch a break yeah a
lovely girl
also hisses - the fact that Alice and
chick were trying to play clue everyone
knows that you need at least three
players to make that game work plus I'll
save you some time it was creepy Colonel
chick in the dining room
the lamp he's closed as for those kisses
I'm sending that first one to Betty for
finally opening up and telling Jughead
the truth well about the murder at least
and kisses to the Jones boys for being
the go-to guys for how to dispose of a
body and make a car disappear apparently
these skills are now very useful in
Riverdale these days in a week there'll
be nothing left not even his teeth
kisses to Veronica for doing the right
thing and giving me McCoy a heads up
before she was slut-shamed out of the
office and kisses to Hermione for
proving that behind every strong man
there was an even stronger woman and
looking fabulous in an outfit and lastly
kisses to Cheryl for being back and
looked me badass and for being a total
sweetheart in this episode not only does
she stand up to Hal
she was also very concerned for Betty in
her own Sharyl way you have puke on your
collar alright guys that was a lot and
that does it for this week's after show
episode of Sweetwater secrets now hit
the comments right now or chat with me
on Twitter and tell me your top hisses
and kisses of the week plus were you
surprised by the Hermione twist and what
kind of secrets do you guys think chick
is hiding now as always please give this
video a like and subscribe to e t--'s
YouTube page so you never miss my
Riverdale obsessed rants on Sweetwater
secrets bye guys love you
[Music]